hey guys I'm Ryan and tonight we're
gonna be watching the official trailer
the second official trailer for Godzilla
or Gojira or go here ah sounds like it
could be the name of a viagra I learned
something today that I thought was
really interesting go hero lore Gojira I
don't know the roland emmerich version
of Godzilla which was a big piece of
[ __ ] by the way and I'm so glad
everyone's moving past that now
what did that suck if this new one is
worse than that one I seriously doubt it
will be though that first trailer alone
was better than the entire roland
emmerich film but I'll let you in on a
little secret I see really like the role
in M reg film yeah this is um the second
trailer and I loved everything I saw
from the first one it looks dark it
looks really menacing like Godzilla
really feels like a terror in this one a
real monster I don't know how I let
emmerich [ __ ] that up and like the cast
is already awesome just the fact that
Brian [ __ ] Cranston is in this is
[ __ ] incredible anything this guy
does now he's gonna be compelling and
breaking bad like you're so good
he made me I want to cook crystal meth
I'm gonna smoke some meth right now
before I watch this trailer
mr. white there's a [ __ ] giant lizard
over there
Jesse will handle it I hope this
Godzilla movie plays out more like that
and this is [ __ ] like legendary
pictures okay they made the 300 films
they didn't make 300 films they made the
you know the you know this is sparta he
talks like this side of his face the
whole time they're making them as
Superman films they made the Dark Knight
trilogy they practically made all in
Nolan's films these guys are [ __ ]
huge like some things and that before to
watch this trailer fun fact
Gojira is actually a combination of two
Japanese words one word means whale and
the other word means gorilla and they
combine it he's a goryeo he's a whale
Rilla it's whale and gorilla kinda
defines a fire-breathing lizard doesn't
it I've had like 65 million people tell
me to watch this damn trailer right when
it was released you know it's funny
about all you guys I've talked to all
you guys all the time you're in my
youtube circle [ __ ] you guys will tell
me watch this trailer here's the most
recent example watch the rise of electro
trailer and then I like those
guys I'm gonna watch the rise of electro
trailer so I watched the rise of electro
trailer and I'm like cool I can't wait
to hear what they got to say about this
trailer reaction and you guys don't say
anything about the trailer reaction what
you immediately say is watch the new
Godzilla trailer
I can't wait for more trailer
recommendations but no commentary on the
actual video no if you want to make a
commentary on the video please please do
love Bryan Cranston he's gonna be great
in this I met him once yeah he's like
the nicest dude I met him on the set of
malcolm in the middle' him and I had a
pizza together he's like you should come
on the show sometime I was like oh stop
it Brian yeah he was flirting with me we
did stuff here we go the second trailer
which I hear is significantly more epic
than the first Warner Brothers legendary
the traffic is so annoying
you're lying it was not an earthquake it
wasn't a typhoon
because what's really happening just
much chills right now is it bright
France and just make it that much better
whoa the Statue of Liberty always gets
[ __ ] up
[Music]
whoa damn I love the way shot
in 1954 we awakened
[Music]
whoa
they're outside
[ __ ] you music said creepy
no idea
[Music]
getting with the dummy damn character
Johnson let's go
[Music]
the audience of man is thinking nature
is in our control
oh gosh yeah that's how you take out
Godzilla flares great effects great
effects [ __ ] roar
Oh
we gotta see him IMAX yes I'm so glad
this is on IMAX that would that all if
you've never been on IMAX what what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
a sock you know one subscriber and he's
like I go on IMAX but it's two hours
away I'm telling you right now it's
worth a day's trip to go I'm dying to
see on IMAX this is a 3d and some movies
have been rocking it with 3d lately okay
right off the bat right what I love
about this
he feels like a [ __ ] monster again it
doesn't feel like some like sci-fi
action adventure flick which is always
like and cool but the way you know me
know how Roland Emmerich is this film
just looks like haunting and menacing
you got to give bryan cranston a lot of
[ __ ] credit for this what I love
about a good actor in such a fantasy
thing like this when they believe it so
much that you believe in more and like
that fear that he has that like
pressured oh oh dude it's just you buy
the situation even more because he
believes it so much and like I'm excited
to see Aaron taylor-johnson too because
you know he's like kind of a dweeby okay
look all right kick-ass he's pretty
kick-ass at times but let's admit he's
kind of a dweeb in that film in this
movie he looks like a badass man if
we're gonna see a whole new serious side
of that good-looking [ __ ]
and I think I think her name is
elizabeth Olsen one of the people who's
not a twin of the Olsons and she is very
attractive I am going to think about her
right before I go to bed you know what's
gonna happen next
yeah and this film looks scary to like
it actually looks scary
Oh the directing and cinematography of
it all alone is just it seems like it's
worth watching just for that [ __ ]
because it looks beautiful but it looks
like like I said menacing and of course
God [ __ ] Zilla you get like a little
bit different mmm that one part ya know
that one part where you finally see them
you're like that's pretty [ __ ] scary I
love the way they're promoting this film
like just the secrecy behind me like you
get glimpses of him and not a real clear
image I hope most of the film go
that way cuz I think who would keep
Godzilla scarier just the way it shot
like it just intensifies the fear of
everything you know like I noticed for a
lot of shots like the camera keeps
rolling it's not like a bunch of crazy
editing the whole time it looked I mean
that's the trailer at least I don't know
if the movies gonna try other way hope
it does and like that one part where all
the planes are just like crushing I was
like damn that's [ __ ] creepy like
this really looks like a film that's
taking this seriously
like fans were do not happy with how
that role and Emeric piece of [ __ ]
turned out this one it's like the hip
you know I like I like it when a studio
seems to listen to its fans yeah I heard
they're rebooting gods as I add whatever
and then is it's you know I'm in the
music the [ __ ] music that better be
the score in this film because that
music is terrifying yeah this looks like
a science fiction monster terror film we
have not been able to get a good monster
horror film in a long time like I know
the host is foreign film that got a lot
of great you know reviews and [ __ ] but
like in terms of American cinema it's
been a while cuz like I know clover
fields a monster movie and that's scary
and stuff but you know it's not like the
monsters called Cloverfield or we don't
even really know what the [ __ ] that is
you know we just have Pacific Rim but
that's like an action film in a lot of
ways you know this looks like oh [ __ ] a
terror is coming it's the god of Zyliss
of lizards it's this giant eye in
general don't like lizards anything
reptile like I hate snakes or my biggest
fear I hate snakes Indiana Jones the
effects on Godzilla look great just a
little teases you get like that looks
real and this film looks like it has
like not just like you know good actors
in it it looks like they actually took
time to really get to know its
characters like at one point Bryan
Cranston's is like crying his eyes out
man really touching [ __ ] kojirou and
yeah um see that button hit it and you
subscribe because the community of
subscribers that that we currently have
and that's growing is like it's awesome
like really awesome like these guys are
really cool you'll see like we have long
ass conversations I love to and yeah
please subscribe let's talk I'd also
like you know more trailer suggestions
I'm sorry
like type them out instead of going my
memory huh see somebody went to college
whale and gorilla that's what some
people and by people I mean fine-ass
ladies call a little ride nothing like
any on a good dick joke
I believe San Diago means whales vagina